haben sie das auch schon mal erlebt sind
allein unterwegs und haben plötzlich das
gefühl es folge ihnen jemand kennen sie
vielleicht sogar orte wo es spukt nun
wohl bei fast allen völkern gibt es die
vorstellung von allen geistern aber auch
von untoten die sich bemerkbar machen
wenn sie keine ruhe finden
auch zu unserem kulturellen erbe gehört
diese art von magischem denken das zeigt
sie eindeutig der film arme seelen des
luzern regisseurs edwin beeler anhand
von ausschnitten aus diesem film
diskutiert politiker mit dem historiker
und schriftsteller pirmin maier und zwar
über eben jene phänomene des
übersinnlichen pirmin maier sie sind ein
experte der religiösen volkskunde sie
befassen sich unter anderem mit
mystischen erlebnissen von personen
sie befassen sich auch zum beispiel mit
geister häusern geister faden in der
innerschweiz haben sie einen hautumm
übernatürlichen das würde ich sagen das
wird nicht gut herauskommen wenn dies
mein erstes motiv wäre
sie können zum beispiel nicht
gleichzeitig spezialist für werwölfe und
werwolf sein sondern sie müssen
versuchen die dinge die sie beobachten
zu verstehen und nicht sich selber
wieder vordergrund zu rücken
aber sie sind schon das was sie bewegen
sich gerne in grenzgebieten sie befassen
sich gerne auch mit personen die
grenzgänger sind paracelsus zum beispiel
cg jung das ist schon ein gebiet das ein
neues das ist völlig richtig aber diese
grenzgänger
ich möchte dazu noch unter klaus
erwähnen sind zwar außergewöhnliche und
geheimnisvolle persönlichkeiten aber
letztlich repräsentanten schweizerische
identität und ich finde es interessant
aus
gerade durchschnittlich und normale
menschen eben dieser bedeutenden
repräsentanten sind sondern oft solche
die sogar gewisse extreme sein und an
sich haben
würden sie sich selbst ernannt
grenzgänger bezeichnen
das kann ich nun übertragenen sinn sagen
grenzgänger insofern also ich überzeugt
bin dass beispielsweise literatur
betrachtung das genügt nicht geschichte
genügt nicht politik genügt nicht
sondern die dinge müssen miteinander
verbunden werden und letztlich bin ich
sogar überzeugt um die schweiz zu
verstehen braucht es sogar eine
theologische und auch mythologische
mythische perspektive was wir in dieser
sendung jetzt besprechen möchten sind
die phänomene wie verstorbene die noch
warten so genannte arme seelen wir
machen das in hand wie angekündigt von
beispielen aus dem film von edwin beeler
der hals arme seelen an dieser film
bereist mystische landschaften der
innerschweiz wo alteingesessene
spannende geschichten erzählen über
begegnungen mit untoten über andere
mysteriöse vorfälle dieser film wertet
das erzählte nicht sondern erhört
einfach zu und das wollen wir auch tun
mit diesen ersten beispiel
[Musik]
die land bedeutet mir aus ich weiß doch
nie in ein anderes worden
oktober das ist eine schöne andere
bürger haben wir sie erwartet und die
aktien aber nach 80 jahren ja auch was
macht man mal das leben das heißt man
aber es ist zwei mal
das hat mir aber das machen wir das
nicht können
eine prämie sogar gestorben ich mir das
gar nicht ausgemacht roten teppich mit
nanotechnologie goslar monaco
ich bin mit einem baby tiko etc müssen
und ich glaube da haben ich habe mir
gedacht mit 1000 jeden fall bin ich froh
endlich zu stephan ihren schnitt wird
geschäftig ganz sensibel wahnsinnig wenn
ihre bisherige vorstand stefan helft mir
ich sage mediziner gut im griff
vielleicht & cie
[Musik]
geht oder wenn überhaupt sucht doch dass
ich diese tablet ähnliche projekte
wurden die katalytische hinten raus
diese vater und der großvater mit seinen
stehe ich war abgeschnitten und 1000 und
der wenigen aber versagte blöd wenn ich
den schulen bisher als zehnter wieder
fabrik in der zwölf wm als glücklich
auch wenn ich nicht beim bad bellingen
hobbits laufen sondern außer form oder
es müsste nur recht und billig für wii
und den ds pc und ich immer in den
kommenden wochen will die kommission ihr
und respektlose und haben die daumen
[Musik]
ja hier erzählt die bäuerin erzähler
bucher zweierlei also sie erzählt wie
sie mit ihrem verstorbenen kind in
kontakt bleibt und sie erzählt von
begegnungen mit einer wandelnden seele
wenn das erste ist ja wahrscheinlich gar
nicht so außergewöhnlich
ich denke viele menschen bleiben
irgendwie in kontakt mit verstorbenen im
kanton luzern besonders im luzerner
hinterland hat das aber durchaus auch
mit brauchtum zu tun
josef tillmann der große meister der
hinterländer volkskunde vor 20 jahren
verstorben verweist darauf dass man zum
beispiel im raum wie dies auch noch
mindestens 30 tage für die verstorbenen
getippt hat was also setzte der bucher
hier macht das hat also insofern ein
zusammenhang mit dem was brauch ist aber
im grunde genommen hat es auch ein
zusammenhang mit den tiefsten strukturen
des toten kultus denken sie an
archäologische funde wo man eben speisen
bei toten findet oder dass man toten
eine münze in den mund legt das hat eben
damit zu tun dass es nachher weitergeht
aber viel wichtiger scheint wie hier
aber der kontakt den sie mit ihrem sohn
hat und sie betont auch dass dieser sohn
ihr hilft das ist unglaublich sind recht
mit dem und sie kriegt antwort ja dass
das ist von bedeutung dieser tote hat
noch eine funktion der wir nicht einfach
entsorgt der existiert in dieser art und
weise weiter und irgendwie erinnert mich
an das wort eines philosophen der gesagt
hat einen menschen lieben heißt sagen
du wirst nicht sterben also immer auch
nicht zu vergessen ihn in der
gemeinschaft behalten nicht vergessen
und das was sie mit der gemeinschaft
haben ist sagen ist umso wichtiger denn
besonders jetzt auch in der innerschweiz
im kanton uri oder im kanton wallis
trinkwasser land kann man von einer
gemeinschaft der lebenden und der toten
sprechen beispielsweise auch die
beerdigungs bräuche etwa im
freiburgischen betonen dass sehr stark
diese gemeinschaft was sehen sie dann
bist du den todesanzeigen wenn etwa
steht es ist die schwiegermutter des
präsidenten des fußballklubs gestorben
also die gemeinschaft die leidet mit und
zeigt ihre solidarität
cäcilia bucher sieht man auch wie sie in
der kapelle kerzen anzündet die lichter
an sind für verstorbene das ist etwas
was es auch nicht nur jetzt im
christlichen in der christlichen
tradition gibt darum macht man das warum
kerzen
das geht sehr in die tiefe natürlich
heißt das christliche ganz katholische
gebet herr gebiet die ewige ruhe und das
ewige licht leuchte aber es geht
effektiv noch tiefer mit dieser kerze
wie dieser verbundenheit der liebe
dadurch wird gesagt dein leben und mein
leben stehen im gleichen großen
zusammenhang und natürlich zündet man
dann nicht nur eine kerze an sondern
noch mehrere andere kerzen ist es ganz
ganz wichtig dass bei jedem anzünden
einer kerze ein wunsch geäußert wird
könnte dazu vielleicht eine kleine
geschichte aus dem kanton luzern
erzählen was ich selber erlebt habe wir
sind mal einige lehrerinnen und lehrer
in eine ziemlich dunkle kapelle gegangen
und haben deswegen die ex fotos also
diese beigaben und die kulturell
interessanten sachen nicht richtig sehen
können
also haben dann einige kerzen angezündet
dann sagte aber eine lehrerin solche
kerzen sind nicht dazu da um geld zu
machen sondern solche kerze sind dazu da
um etwas zu wünschen
das ist dann notabene auch einem lehrer
aufgefallen
und der ist dann nachher nach haus
gekommen von diesem heiligtum sankt
ottilien gutes holz dass ein heiligtum
einerseits gegen augenleiden ist aber
auch bei familienstreitigkeiten hilft
und jetzt kommt die pointe eine woche
später vermerkte diese noch junge lehrer
es ist unglaublich jetzt habe ich eine
kerze angezündet
und was passiert wenn ich heimkomme die
schwiegermutter ruft an erstmals nach
zwei jahren
bucher im film ein spieler die erzählt
dann weiter von ihren begegnungen mit
einem untoten also da kommt auch das
licht wieder vor sie sagt das sei immer
so ein helles licht gewesen wie ein
blitz und danach sah sie diese dunkle
gestalt und der pfarrer sagte dann das
ist eine arme seele die wandeln muss
einmal was genau sind arme seelen eben
untote werden sie bezeichnet in der
allgemeinen europäischen volkskunde und
ein und riss einer der auf erden noch
etwas zu erledigen hat
weil irgend ein schweres problem nicht
gelöst wurde auch ein unrecht wurde
nicht gesühnt
das macht ihn zum untoten durchaus gibt
es auch junge mütter die wandeln und die
beispielsweise schauen ob ihre kinder in
guter obhut sind zb bei der neuen arbeit
bei der stiefmutter das kann man bei der
geburt gestorben ist immer ganz genau
dann geht sie allenfalls sie können
natürlich das auch vielleicht
psychologisch deuten und können sie
fragen hat vielleicht der vater ein
schlechtes gewissen dass er jetzt diesen
kindern eine stiefmutter vorsetzt
umgekehrt bleibt natürlich die sehnsucht
der kinder nach ihrer mutter und dass
diese mutter dann wieder kommt das ist
irgendwie nicht verwunderlich
aber sie sagen also arme seelen die
wandeln müssen das sind solche die
irgendwie noch es gibt noch eine haftung
zu er dass sie können sich nicht ganz
lösen versteht es ist tatsächlich war
eine verbundenheit und letztlich wieder
wäre ja von den lebenden ausgehen und
überall wo solche geschichten erzählt
werden
dort nimmt man die die toten im höchsten
grade erst das kann man sagen also sie
einfach hin zu vergessen oder gar zu
entsorgen das kommt nicht in frage
stellt sich auch immer wieder die frage
was hätte da tote jetzt dazu gesagt
aber eben doch auch wenn ein problem
nicht gelöst wird wenn sogenannte leiche
im keller da ist dann wundert es eben
nicht dass solche personen umgehen
das habe ich zum beispiel in peru
münster beziehungsweise in der nähe von
peer münster kunst will entsprechend
erfahren dass stellen sie sich mal vor
in einen ganz bestimmten zimmer dem
oberen stock hat nie jemand geschlafen
hat sich nie dort unnötig aufgehalten
hat vielleicht die militärs effekten um
die haus dokumente dort versorgt aber
sonst nichts
und zwar warum man hörte stimmen man
hörte merkwürdige geräusche
was steckt dahinter vor bald 150 jahren
ist dort eine schwiegertochter also eine
frau und schwiegertochter vom bauern ist
ein spieler mit sehr speziell ist bei
jedem raum gestorben
nicht einfach gestorben sondern wie es
in gerichtsakten heißt beseitigung einer
ehefrauen schwiegertochter durch
einsperren und allmählich es verhungern
lassen und das ist natürlich dann in
jenem raum wo diese frau verhungerte
noch generationen lang nicht richtig
waren
das verwundert nicht aber die wahre
potente ist eigentlich die folgende wenn
immer wieder eine neue frau in jenes
haus hinein geheiratet hat wurde sie
natürlich über diesen befund des
gespenster zimmers nicht unterrichtet
und darum hat sich das haus selber
gemeldet
und das finde ich gar nicht so
irrational
denn wenn wir eben die probleme unter
den teppich vision dann kommen sie
irgendwann zum vorschein und insofern
sehe hier einen tiefsee in dieser
geschichte also jetzt ohne dass man das
jetzt wirklich so glauben müsste aber es
hat schon eine bedeutung sagen sie aber
noch mal zurück zu den ich sage jetzt
normalen armen seelen wir empfehlen
erwähnt wurde hat das auch etwas mit mit
der fähige feuer vorstellung zu tun also
eine art zwischenzustand die sind ja
nicht mehr lebendig aber auch nicht im
himmel also wo sind die ja
selbstverständlich hat es mal zu tun mit
den vorstellungen was bedeutet der toten
was kommt nach dem tod
und eigentlich gibt es nur die vier
letzten dinge im christlichen weltbild
nämlich himmel und hölle
der tod und das gericht aber das
fegefeuer das erste französische volks
kontakt glückauf gesagt hat es vor etwa
1000 jahren erfunden wurde das fegefeuer
das gibt sozusagen die die chance dass
man weder einfach im himmel ist doch
einfach in der hölle sondern in einem
zwischen zustand ich gehe so weit zu
sagen dieser zwischenzustand ist wohl
nicht einfach eine erfindung und zwar
deswegen nicht weil unzählige menschen
eben erfahrungen gemacht haben die sie
sich nicht anders erklären konnte aber
ins werden gibt es schon eine parallele
zu diesen armen seelen das ist richtig
aber eben das
in diesem sie sagen fegefeuer sind und
tatsächlich weder die probleme der leben
hauptsächlich die nicht aber eben auch
die schuld des toten
die sind nicht genügend gebüsst und
irgendwie akzeptieren wir wohl die ewige
hölle die vollständige verdammnis schwer
und wir können leichter uns eine
übergangszeit vorstellen und diese
übergangszeit wiederum hat ja eine
gewisse parallele auch mit der tatsache
dass wir mit allen toten abschied von
allen toten abschied nehmen müssen dass
uns dieser abschied sehr schwer fällt
umgekehrt wenn er uns zu leicht fällt
dann erinnert sich erinnert der tote
selbst daran dass es ihn noch gibt aber
könnte man das nicht auch missbrauchen
also oder hat die kirche vielleicht auch
missbraucht indem sind dass man den
leuten nach droht dass man sagt wenn ihr
in eurem leben dinge unerledigt lässt
oder wenn ihr sünder seit und dann
stirbt dann müsst ihr nach verwandeln
also kann es ja keine schöne vorstellung
die sache mit dem wandel steht natürlich
weder in der bibel
noch ist es die lehre der katholischen
kirche sondern das wandeln hat nun
tatsächlich mit der volks überlieferung
zu tun und hauptsächlich wohl mit der
germanischen volks überlieferung also
dass die toten wandlung und dass die
toten gewiss
wege gehen das finden sie im ganzen
germanischen raum und das finden sie
jetzt zum beispiel auch in meinem
heimatkanton aargau seinen eigentlichen
toten weg gibt entlang des halses und
dieser total weg wird beispielsweise
durch ein haus versperrt das möbelhaus
in beinwil am see
da gibt es gar nichts anderes als dass
in diesem haus das scheunentor immer
offen bleiben muss vorn und hinten dass
das heer der toten die übrigens von
süden nach norden heimgehen dass dieses
heer der toten seinen weg gehen kann
solche geschichten will siemens in
island und irland
genau gleich wir haben dazu eine
geschichte
sie spielt auf einer alp im kanton uri
dass er unser zweiter vielen beitrag
danke
[Musik]
wenn wir hier die samen hinten in den
kongo sind nach teppich kohle oder eines
imagefilms ist nur komisch warum ich ihn
aus
[Musik]
daher ist es immer wieder mitmischen
kühl hinter der startlinie kommen
der geist gottes und die zuschauer waren
begeistert die hochpunkte kopf und denkt
die züge millionär floss köpfe des
verschwindens noch leidlich hochschule
[Musik]
wismar und nach ritters meinte der
fertig stattdessen wurde eine reserve
mit das heißt es
noch riecht es förmlich die bahnen
hinter dem ort gezogen und ich komme
sage versteht muss ich das noch keiner
hätte er gleich viele bahnen nicht mit
das ist nicht der fall
bitte ehe stefan
also jetzt das bt
immer wieder ist er wurde aus gestalten
um doch rät mehr im rennen
weil ich ihn mir in kontakt komme
irgendwie ort sprechen
hallo
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ja der sig hat ein sehr rutschigen
dialektisch vielleicht muss man auch ein
bisschen verständnis hilfe anbieten er
sagt ein mädchen habe der geist
innerebner ihnen gewirkt also wenn ich
richtig verstehe hat dieser geist das
mädchen in einem futtertrog gekrönt und
sich fast gestorben
gut nun wenn aufgeklärte zeitgenossen
oder solche die sich dafür halten solche
geschichten hören haben sie sich
vielleicht die augen und fragen sich was
sehen wir denn hier gelandet sind wir
mit lauter zurück oder was ist los
wie gehen sie an solche geschichten
hören was ist der fokus natürlich gibt
es sogenannte plagegeister man spricht
zum beispiel vom doppel dem alltag und
es kann auch sein dass sogar diese
geschichte die vielleicht etwas
zensuriert daher kommt sogar mit dem
missbrauch eines kindes zu tun hat wenn
es sehr viele sagen im kanton luzern
auch berichten beispielsweise wenn man
vor allem vom meierhof in sempach
erzählt ein mädchen das sei der so
genannten strecken gegeben worden um es
angeblich zu bestrafen die strecke sei
vorüber ziehende hexe und jetzt musste
sich ein knecht angeblich diese strecke
verkleidet und dann hat man also auf
diese weise das mädchen erschrecken
wollen
was ist in wirklichkeit passiert das
mädchen war entführt und man hat dann
seine kleid auf einem baum gefunden und
das erinnert dann natürlich wohl schon
an ein verbrechen umso mehr als in
gedenkt
april zu dieser tat ein mühlstein
drinnen aufgestellt ist nach dem
bibelwort es wäre leichter man würde
sich einem mühlstein um den hals hängen
und sich ins wasser werfen aus einem
kind ergeben
sie merken an solchen geschichten und
überlieferungen dass vieles was wir
heute gerichteten polizeilich abklären
und vieles was früher tabu war längst
ähnlich schlimm oder noch schlimmer
existierte und dass diese entsprechenden
probleme sich dann im zeichen system des
geister reiches manifestierte
also man hat geschichten verbrechen
unter den teppich gekehrt sind nicht
aufgeklärt aber die machen sich dann in
form von solchen geschichten und sagen
wieder gemerkt die machen sich dann
bemerkbar
das klingt jetzt so also sie haben jetzt
bei vielen geschichten eine erklärung
dazu abgegeben also verstehe ich sie
dann richtig dass sie eigentlich die
geschichten so wie sie erzählt werden
nicht glauben sie glauben nicht dass es
geister gibt die die sich bemerkbar
machen
ich glaube diese frage ist so falsch
gestellt was es gibt ist die unsichtbare
welten zu dieser unsichtbare welt
gehören zum beispiel auch die normen des
gewissens und wenn diese normen des
gewissens eben massiv übertreten wurden
dann manifestiert sich das auf
irgendeine art und weise und insofern
bin ich überhaupt nicht der meinung dass
sind unglaubwürdige geschichte sogar
sehr sehr ernst zu nehmende geschichten
und diese geschichten haben eine
mitteilung an die nachgeborenen und an
die lebenden
ich glaube es war auch die
sennentuntschi geschichte die man nicht
übrigens einfach zu einem alpen porno
vertreten darf wir hatten sehr sehr
tiefen hintergrund die die hat
eigentlich was zu sagen aber es bleibt
für sie eben immer weltlichen als das
hat nichts mit jenseitigen
übernatürlichem übersinnlichen zu tun so
wie ich sie jetzt wahrnehmen erklären
sich vieles psychologisch auch natürlich
kann man das psychologisch erklären aber
schon der dichter novalis hat vermerkt
die psychologie ist eine der waffen die
dort steht wo einst ware götterbilder
aufgestellt waren und ich bin ziemlich
sicher dass es verschiedene probleme
gibt die der mensch sich nicht nur
psychologisch erklären lassen kann und
ihm letztlich der tod ein solches
problem sie können den tod nicht weg
psychologisieren sondern sie müssen sich
ihm stellen und über den tod heißt es ja
herr engel so steht es in der geheimen
offenbarung kant der philosophie zitiert
ist der engel blies die posaune und
verkündete dass hinfort keine zeit sein
soll
und das bedeutet dass nach dem tod die
ewigkeit kommt und wie ich mich zu
dieser ewigkeit stelle notabene in
diesem leben ist eine ganz entscheidende
ethische frage die beispiele die wir
sehen und überhaupt der ganze film
spielt er in einer sehr katholisch
geprägten und auch in einer sehr
ländlichen welt heißt es jetzt es ist
auch ein phänomen dieser materiellen
geschichte ein phänomen das typisch
katholisch ländlich jetzt der wandel der
toten ist auf jeden fall nicht einfach
ein katholisches phänomen wenn sie eben
beispielsweise die schon genannten
aargau sagen und aargau überlieferungen
zum teil überlieferungen die noch ganz
neues bemerken dann ist es nicht
unbedingt katholisch oder stellen sich
den belchen tunnel vor
es ist erstaunlich dass sogar die
autobahn mittlerweile im magischen ort
geworden ist weil es immer wieder
vorgekommen sein soll dass auf dem etwas
diskreten rastplatz vor dem belchen
tunnel in richtung basel auf der
südlichen seite dass dort jemand ins
auto einsteigt und während der fahrt
durch den belchen tunnel ist ein
plötzlich verschwunden
dass sie nicht erfahrungen von
katholiken oder ob man noch anderes
beispiel zu bringen als die allergrößte
sorge um die freiheit und sicherheit und
um das überleben der schweiz herrschte
im mai 1940 etwa im raum basel land oder
im raum magden rheinfelden was passieren
könnte von deutschland her
in diesem moment haben menschen die
nicht katholisch waren wie zum beispiel
eine frau martha bruch aber die figur
von bruder klaus haben sie den wolken
gesehen
sie konnte es solche figur aber nur
sehen weil sie das zuerst in ihrem
innersten herzen gesehen haben und
gemerkt haben jetzt gilt es ganz ernst
und dieser befund ist eben auch bei der
frage leben und tod gestellt eben der
tod und das gericht habe ich das was ich
in meinem leben geschafft habe wirklich
richtig gemacht oder habe ich etwas ganz
ganz schlimmes angestellt
es stellt sich die frage ob diese ob
diese ethische herausforderung nicht
auch heute gestellt werden könnte also
will heißen es ist heute zu wenig raum
für solche gedanken
das behaupte ich gar nicht also sich
haben jetzt bei diesen menschen gesehen
dass sie noch eine beziehung sogar die
traditionell geprägte beziehung zu den
toten haben heute diversifiziert sich
das natürlich es gibt personen die
stellen in ihrem wohnzimmer
die von angehörigen auf und und lassen
das wohnzimmer und dann wieder andere
die legen wert darauf dass ihre asche
irgendwo verstreut wird und ich glaube
schon dass die herausforderung der durch
den tod auch heute existiert nicht
darauf dass jugendliche durchaus über
diese fragen ganz intensiv diskutieren
können ich möchte gerne darauf zu
sprechen kommen weil sie viel mit
jugendlichen zu tun haben
lassen sie uns aber zuerst einen dritten
film als schnitt anschauen
dieser führt uns ins stechen kann
[Musik]
ich habe hautnah jenter minute besser
gefunden dass er so unglücklich
gemeinden im stau und so celik ball
sie sind schwarz blockiert wurden sie im
stau geißler freikarten auf jungs noch
zu geld von mir gehört der geistigen
fitness pflichtete ihm untersuchen raus
weg die mund eines mache ich das tor
ziehen sich durch etliche sachen einfach
basierte meter kleiner kreuzer ganzen
der gefahrenanalyse kreativ und deine
sperma nach samstagmorgen und ich glaube
und akzeptieren in der ruby herzlich an
sich liegt frisch damit wenn man seither
übt und da nicht dank der schon als auch
elektronisch mein gehalt von damals
verlassen und danach ohne hast du das
hier nicht ganz wieder getan wird um den
kontakt zur nachhut unter und hinter
vertrauen das ich habe einfach und jetzt
nehmen sie trug sich an einem tag
jetzt weiß ich schon als messe mit
geballter hinter kann ich als vater war
patrons debatte richtiger fan nachricht
dass auf sie hat kein mensch nie mix aus
vorarlberg sich noch sauber tag einen
dank zu hinterlassen
machen und da eine private kasse und das
bier alle welt und heimat der aktivismus
gewartet und dann plötzlich wie komisch
ich hinten und so machen sie noch nicht
dass losgegangen sein und rheinischem
bruce pinien das sind 2000 trafen die
kinder flug war wie im flug sind sieben
euro was platz gehandicapt und zwei
handgriffen messe berlin oder lafer und
das spätere patienten kommen und der
neuen tags das wieder das gleiche wie
dem medium mit ohne tankstopps nicht nur
schwarz kunst als müsse sich räuber
ich glaube ich mehr mendener leser
und als rasch die 1000 ich bitte daher
aus einer der gnade barmherzigen die
ewige reagiert berater der bescheiden
wenn aus der realistisch er bete für
dich mehr bietet als ein signal ich aber
herzlich
[Musik]
und der letzte der noch beherrschen wer
so viel genau ist realistisch und
reibungsfrei tonne kontakte zwischen der
leester und auftakt der faulheit zwei
motiven sehr und da nicht eine packung
mit stickern sieger sowie bestimmt mir
da einfach nicht ich glaube dass ich
weiß schon was dahintersteckt gerät noch
nicht ableiten toller ganz böse verona
oder hanoi und tonal begrüßen wird
ohne die heiligen erzengel ersten
semester gemacht und kraft gottes itella
verstoßen
ja damit klar mit und die bösen geister
wenn die unermessliche macht und kraft
das ist schrank aber wiese und der
verbraucher verriegelung versickere
gestanden da war weil sich gedulden
ja der warum tyler josef stadler erzählt
hier fällt über spuk ereignisse in
seinem stall und erzählt davon wir einen
jungen von einem geist befreit mit
gebeten also erzählt von einem
exorzismus ist jetzt diese vorstellung
von besessenheit durch geister ist das
etwas was häufig vorkommt der
christlichen volksfrömmigkeit
ich würde sagen es kommt nicht mehr so
häufig vor aber man kann sagen
vor 200 300 400 jahren war das zum
beispiel die psychotherapie der
kapuziner die medizinhistoriker ins exil
ernst hat etwa 16 fälle von exorzismus
analysiert und was mir dort aufgefangen
ist wenn ein exorzist eine echte heiler
begabung hat einen heiler ransmann dann
ist ihm unter der voraussetzung dass ja
alle das gleiche weltbild haben diese
voraussetzung ist über seine
psychotherapie nötig unter dieser
voraussetzung kann durchaus erfolgreich
gearbeitet werden wenn aber der exorzist
was leider vorkommen kann selber ein
perverser tipp ist dann kommt der teufel
sozusagen mal sieben zurück recht der
der exorzismus ist also in diesem sinn
eine sehr zwiespältige gefährliche
therapie form von der sich die
katholische kirche mehr und mehr
distanziert obwohl es den exorzismus
immer noch gibt und obwohl zum beispiel
das kommt diesen film vor
der propst von beromünster herr einmal
seelsorgerin produktiver dieser probst
von peer münster der macht zwar keine
exorzismen aber noch heute segnete
häusern in denen es gespenster und wenn
das dann die entsprechende wirkung hat
mit dem gegenseitigen zutrauen der
gemeinsamen glauben dann wundert es mich
überhaupt nicht dass es nach einer
solchen regelung nicht mehr gespenster
und dass man also sagen kann die
therapie hat einigen volk es werden
jetzt ihre schüler sagen wenn sie sonst
werden sie sind geben als lehrer an der
kantonsschule beromünster passende
schüler zu solchen geschichten sagen es
hat schon schüler gegeben die erzählt
haben in unserem haus gespenster best
schon seit jahrhunderten abwehr
wir haben uns damit abgefunden dass
dafür gibt es wasser usw
aber das ist schon nicht mehr der
normalfall
was die schüler vielleicht noch eher
interessiert von kurios wert her ist
natürlich der vampirismus und der im
moment auch im kino gerade hier muss man
sagen vom kino her kann man ganz fertig
vorstellung bekommen wenn ich jetzt an
neben den film von edwin beeler denke
vampire sind wiedergänger also solche
die noch keine ruhe im grabe gefunden
hatten und vampire äußern das eben auch
entsprechend chaotisch und dann sagt man
vampire ziehen andere die noch leben
diese untoten vampire ziehen andere nach
sich
so war es zum beispiel einem dorf im
grazer land noch 1835 aus dort ein wird
gestorben war setzte ein sterben ein und
wie hat man reagiert etwas anders als in
rumänien man hat diesen wird nicht
gefällt sondern man hat in exhumiert und
eine typisch schweizerische
im nachbardorf mai gesetzt darüber
möchte ich dann nochmal eine genauere
analyse schreiben heute aber zum
beispiel im dorf anderes den rumänien
wird noch ein herz stich gemacht wenn
menschen beigesetzt werden
man geht also davon aus dass diese
menschen die noch keinen frieden
gefunden haben dass die andere schädigen
köln und das ist wohl der tiefere sinn
auch von ruhe sanft und gibt ihm die
ewige ruhe das heißt eben auch er soll
doch wohl nicht mehr zurückkommen und
irgendwann müssen wir von diesen toten
definitiv abschied nehmen können
das bedeutet aber auch dass die toten
selbe von uns sich verabschieden können
müssen als noch mal herr meier
sie können so viele solche geschichten
glauben sie an solche geschichten sie
haben vorhin gesagt ist die falsche
frage aber irgendwie stellt sich die
frage ja trotzdem es ist so all das was
mit diesen geschichten eben passiert ist
die wahrheit über den menschen der
mensch besteht nicht nur aus ration
sondern eben auch aus dem gemüt und der
mensch ist von sich aus auf die ewigkeit
disponiert er befasst sich sein atheist
oder ägyptischer pharao oder katholiken
oder protestanten oder muslimen er wenn
er befasst sich mit dem jenseits
und der philosoph kirkegaard hat einmal
bemerkt tod welche bedeutung kannst du
dem leben geben also die unsere
einstellung zum tod bestimmt unsere
einstellung zu zeit und es ist nun
tatsächlich die dies die entscheidende
frage gibt es im tod eine hoffnung auf
erlösung auf einen frieden wahren
frieden in der ewigkeit oder gibt es das
nicht und das hat dann eben enorme
konsequenzen auf das entsprechende
verhalten
ich glaube schon der gedanke an die
ewigkeit bestimmt bei allen menschen ihr
verhalten in diesem leben im jetzt also
sie würden sagen menschen die nicht an
ein weiterleben nach dem tod glauben gar
nicht die leben anders als solche daran
glauben
das ist sicher richtig nur ist es
überhaupt nicht garantiert dass die
gläubigen deswegen besser leben
die gläubigen können nun tatsächlich
wahnhafte vorstellungen haben und
paracelsus über den ich ein buch
geschrieben habe vermerkt nicht so stark
durch waren missbrauch bar wieder glaube
der glaube es war wieder wie die liebe
eine unserer stärksten qualitäten aber
sie wissen glaube und liebe können auch
am schlimmsten missbraucht werden und
insofern verwundert mich die skepsis und
die kritik der atheisten nicht wie wohl
auch die artisten sich eben die frage
stellen müssen wie sie gegenüber der
ewigkeit ihr leben gestalten was sie
hier als richtig und falsch annehmen
es gibt ja auch versuche da hat es immer
wieder gegeben diesen phänomenen des
übersinnlichen wissenschaftlich auf die
schliche zu kommen mit methoden der
naturwissenschaft auch was halten sie
denn von solchen versuchen
ich würde sagen wie bei allen
wissenschaften muss man ja eine theorie
aufstellen und die theorie wo es um die
es geht ist von mir aus gesehen die
theorie über den menschen
es ist nicht nur anthropologie und
ethnologie und nicht nur psychologie
sondern es geht um die frage was ist der
mensch und der mensch scheint das
lebewesen zu sein das von der ewigkeit
her eine orientierung entdeckt und
insofern ist es dann schon keine
kleinigkeit welche religion man wählt
oder in welcher religion man aufwächst
und selbst eben auch das alte testament
das judentum bringt mit der
sensationellen gespenstergeschichte vom
sound der so genannten hexe von endor
dieses thema wieder zur sprache
indem stellen sie sich mal vor keinen
geringeren als den propheten samuel aus
dem graben um von ihm ratschläge zu
empfangen das ist eigentlich unglaublich
eine solche geschichte in der bibel
also wir heißen wenn wir das verlieren
auch diese erzähltradition jedoch
wahrscheinlich immer mehr verloren geht
ist das wirklich ein verlust also man
könnte ja auch sagen na endlich setzt
sich die aufklärung durch was verlieren
wird denn das behaupten sie das ist
erzählt tradition verloren gehe
wir haben jetzt 200 jahre gebrüder grimm
und die brüder grimm haben ihre sagen
und märchen erzählt weil sie glaubten
sie seien wegen der aufklärung die
letzten die das noch aus
und es war wiederum die aufklärung
selber die diese geschichten
systematisch gesammelt hat und zum teil
auch analysiert und etwa die historische
volkskunde so die ich eintreten würde
ist auf jede weise auch ein kind der
aufklärung und die aufklärung kann uns
eben sagen diese seite des menschen die
gibt es auch und wenn wir sie leugnen
dann machen wir eventuell noch viel
größere wählern
wir wollen zum schluss dieser sendung
noch einmal die beiden älpler energie
bissig und josef stadler zu wort kommen
lassen ihnen firmen meyer
danke ich sehr herzlich dass sie in die
sternstunden gekommen sind vielen dank
für das gespräch
dank ihm einerseits mainz wenig verstand
dann hat sie mit praxis nicht
es sind am ende
felix a ich hoffe man nicht gesehen
haben
der paraguayer bin ich ja auf dem meer
sind rund 100 menschen die ihm glaube
aus teilt er nicht was für dich
das ist ihm dass ich dich und durch das
anbieten
ich muss gleich das persönlich sind ich
sagen immer ich sagen immer mit erst mit
der fremden nutzte den vorteil auf den 1
[Musik]